a beautiful part of the Hall of Fame
speeches is that you're talking about
real life and real life issues in a man
who's all about that is a freshly minted
Pro Football Hall of Famer I love this
man I have love for him I couldn't have
been more happy to see him get enshrined
his his name is Ed Reed back here in the
Rich Eisen show how are you I'm doing
fine
have you been able to serve that guy
speaking well yep this heard that
interview that she was doing the guy's
been in there my heart goes out to him
and all the families you know I tried to
talk with some police officers after
when I was about to leave at the Canton
and Airport there about stuff like that
man and that's exactly what I'll speak
you know what did you how did you decide
what to speak on and I mean I mean you
have so many interests and you are you
are you are comprised of so many
different parts and people that have
influenced you throughout your life how
did you come up with a lot of that stuff
I mean kind of on the run because I was
going to a lot of emotions you know I
got a text at 8:30 about my auntie
passing and you know it's just really so
much you know so much over the years
I've seen you know this stuff I talk
about it cigar aloud this with people
random people from different walks of
life because we all affected about it
you know we we don't like to just the
elephant in the room you know that our
country does have a problem you know our
country has a major problem I have a
[ __ ] our country has a major problem
with our head coach right now who's
leading this country you know on the
things that he said and now he's trying
to retract back on it you know because
it's been close to voting time that's
not that's not right man we need to
understand that the people just divided
country that we need to come together
like we really need to unite under stand
that made a major problem is mental
illness and it's not just affecting you
know black people um Africans in this
country anymore
you know this thing has really gotten
that bad to where it's affecting white
America he's a Mexican everybody is
being affected by this you know so kinda
song video rich and it's really
disturbing video of this young white
Caucasian kid can't think of his name on
a video shooting a box of Jordans man
this is like insane that this kid what
he's talking about and what he's doing
like I'm I have children you know I have
kids growing up that I mentioned and
they're gonna be in school kids like
this like this is crazy man this is it's
madness that you know you think about
these things and have to think about
these things but we need to talk about
it we need to get this stuff addressed
because if you don't know I'm gonna get
worse then obviously you represent the
city of Baltimore which bin has been in
the news in these conversations as well
how much was did where you think we're
thinking mulling about that about how
much to push the gas pedal on that front
you know for that city you know I
understand how bad it is in our school
systems up there I understand how bad
you know monkey will treat it you know
because the resources that the
government won't even allow you to go in
there and help them with you know it's
restrictions you know from a government
standpoint in the school system the next
terrible man you know and I didn't want
to get too political anything up there
I'm not a big Gaga sweep on a lot of it
you know I didn't wanna I didn't want to
kind of drawn out the ceremony with with
certain things but you definitely wanted
to mention it you know asbestos could
and where does that stress is could to
where you bring some attention to you
know our country needed man we need to
be talking about certain things you know
people shouldn't be I'm upset that we're
talking about because these things are
happening you know you know like man you
know these things happen in other
countries and you clear for the people
until it's close to home you know and
right now
it is close to home it is real close to
home you know it's been close to home
these things have been happening
you know us Americans we've been
building with our own terror attack so
to say in this country you know like
we've been doing this you know for a
long time
Pro Football Hall of Famer Ed Reid right
here on the Rich Eisen show let's talk a
little bit about your new home which is
the Pro Football Hall of Fame and who
did you meet this weekend come across
and that's now a fellow gold gold jacket
er that really blew you away they were
like okay I've made it was waiting there
honestly I haven't talked to a lot of
them but you know just beating in that
room being in their present you know has
has really opened my eyes to a lot of
things you know it was awesome being in
that locker room actually woke up this
morning ready to play you know ready to
go to practice with these guys you know
Mel Blount was my guys own you know Mel
have been talking every time you see me
and he he gives me a hug tell me how
proud he is of me you know and he and I
just been talking exchanged numbers I
actually met his son if something hurts
at the pro football playing a kill you
know so it was just really cool to see
him to meet him talk to him you know
being that he's a Steeler even better
you know like the person you hit it off
with you know please for the team's been
the best that right there as long as
we've been the best targets miss blunt
well I was very honored you know to talk
with him I'm gonna be like you know we
need to hang out and play some golf
you know I mean he still looks like ham
and Bruce Smith looks like they could
still give me some snaps and and get
some takeaways to it that's what they
thought about it right that's what that
looks like to me and then what was it
like now that you and Ray Lewis you can
look at each other you're both in that
Club now I mean you
knew it was gonna happen one day deep
down you really probably couldn't voice
it but it's official you and Ray Lewis
back-to-back years Pro Football Hall of
Famers Miami Hurricanes
and so on and so forth what did that
mean now that you your itself it's done
and that book is now written yeah I mean
standard we have in the sander we said
you know except for you know future
Hurricanes future Ravens you know to
understand like you know we put this to
work you know you have to put in some
work you know you have to work together
you know man I'm so excited you know the
fact that it really happened that was
back-to-back you know we we trained so
hard rich great I you know we talked
about some been through so much you know
together and to go in there after my
brother you know you still be on his
team still being that safe to go hunting
you know it's also filling your bust is
amazing I told you this on there on the
network the other night when you joined
us live I mean that thing could go in
the Louvre if not the Hall of Fame it's
perfect Edie I wonder what you think you
know I try to get some snippets of it
you know my ID you know earlier in the
year and I knew it was gonna look like
you know I knew it was a game of Thrones
right field to go ahead look like
wildlings you know like my man like I
said I'm the regional Jon Snow
protecting the wall like you know I knew
I knew what it was gonna be
and Mister but Mr Blair buswell man he
and his wife are awesome um she actually
came in like an hour or so after we was
in there was like you have to do this
hand to make sure we have this hair on
that book can you do this hair like this
and they worked it out and your your
only request was what again for the bus
that you said
just need this what was that I only
needed a if you look closely to my bus
on as you look at it it's on the right
side my left I ran into a mailbox
playing Little League football I mean
not literally got playing street
football on the playground as we called
it at the time in Shrewsbury and I'm
running out for a pass and I got my guy
beat ball at five yards and I can't
remember who was quarterback it threw
the ball sky-high and real far and has
I'm running to get the ball I'm running
I'm running my bodies forward with my
head it all goes back and as the ball
comes down and I catch the ball I hit
the mailbox you know and I have you know
concussed blood everywhere
holding my head like god my head and
hurting my head is hurting and you know
my kids are all the kids like oh your
head we have let us see it let us see it
and as I move my hand I see nothing but
blood and I'm like oh my god oh my
goodness I think I passed out and the
next thing I remember them telling me is
that your dad's going away and sure
enough my dad can pick me up and we went
get stitches and now it's the more like
that star was on there's a football scar
now it's memorialized forever more it's
amazing that's amazing
hey before I let you go add what next
you coaching you got that in you you say
what are you gonna do right now it's
recovery its recovery knowing that's
funny I'm sitting in the house when I
got home last night rich enough I was
just taking notes and reading my book
and listening to Sir John Coltrane and
responding like 12:30 at this point
numbers write things down you know and
one of those questions to myself is look
Nick you know though I've already you
know been working on my foundation my
foundation is my job you know the things
I do in the community in Baltimore I
have my my my golf tournament coming up
there August 19th and I've been doing
for the last 10 plus years and we have a
there with a 1920 steam coming up and
you know that's that's what I do you
know my foundation is what I do you know
I give my story out you know about
people who helped me you know how I
encourage them is to work together and
have unity around you you know it's key
but um okay um I'll be finishing my
cigars
getting the next year sometimes you know
so that'll be a joy for me I got good
business contractors and stuff like that
so we'll see rich there's a couple of
things on man coaching you know yes I
coached my son all the time you know I
think we bout to get back in flag
football I'm here soon so you know he's
number one he's the number one player to
me you know that I have to coach so they
would be able to Baltimore a few times
hopefully I can get around considerably
now you know and help those guys got
over there cuz obviously Baltimore has a
big you know big place in my heart he's
finding my heart sure and I know how
people around always like and once you
come help us once you come down they
don't realize like you just can't up and
show up at certainly I think you know
I'm function I got two more minutes left
dad asking the poll question who better
ask them one of the greatest ball Hawks
of all time Edie read our poll question
Brockman you've got the floor hey
congratulations on your Hall of Fame
pulled today which QB would you want for
the next three years Tom Brady Drew
Brees Phillip Rivers Ben Roethlisberger
the og said would you take if you were
playing on a team which quarterback
would you want for the next three years
Brady just signed a two-year extension
for three years you got to choose one of
those four of our poll question is that
because he had on his glove always know
where 20 years is that why 1 B 1 C you
want to put it John I mean Joe Montana
Tom Brady
you want to put that okay
that's your answer I love it Edie I
couldn't be happier for you I've told
you this a million times and I don't
care who knows it so I'll say it into
the microphone here I love you and I'm
so thrilled for you and I cannot wait to
see anything more from you anything I
can do for you at Ed Reid foundation.org
people can get involved your foundation
anything you know where to reach me
thank you I appreciate that that means
the world and so does my wife Susie
wanted me to send my best to you and
congrats to you - I will I will do that
right back at you Congrats again ed that
was awesome - see that's Edie Reed Pro
Football Hall of Famer at 20 ER for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app